[Musique]
le mahatma gandhi a dit si vous ne
retenez que l'impact de l'inde à
l'humanité retenez la première phrase du
premier livre des humanistes yade qui
dit en essence une même conscience
universelle habite le coeur de chaque
être humain même intelligence universel
habite le coeur de chaque être
cette phrase a bouleversé ma vie avant
ma vie c'était ça je parcourais le monde
à la solde de compagnies pétrolières
pour les accompagner à exploiter des
champs pétroliers sous marins
ici on est à 200 km au large des côtes
africaines à à plus de près de 2000
mètres sous la mer
trop profondément pour qu'on puisse
mettre une plate forme et donc on doit
déployer des prouesses technologiques
pour déporter une partie des équipements
au fond de la mer
un projet de 10 milliards de dollars
pour un milliard de réserves de barils
une période fantastique
et puis un jour j'ai réalisé que 1
milliard de barils de pétrole s'étaient
onze jours de la consommation mondiale
de pétrole oui tout ça pour onze jours
d'orgies énergétique
en fait ce n'était que le membre d'un
cartel qui alimentait le monde dans son
addiction au pétrole et à la croissance
avant entre les avions je rencontrais
mes potes autour d'une bonne bouffe un
bon hamburger steak grillé
puis un jour j'ai rien disait que ce
steak
ils étaient peut-être issus d'un boeuf
élevé en france ou en argentine qui
avait peut-être mangé du soja ogm peut
être cultivée au brésil sur de la forêt
amazonienne brûlé peut-être au prix de
massacres de populations indigènes qui
sait avec des pesticides qui se sont
déversés dans la rivière qui ont fini
dans la mer qui ont construit des
comptes
non de sart gaz qui aujourd'hui se
déverse sur nos plages nous n'avons plus
les moyens de ce mode de vie et
d'ailleurs qui a envie de faire la fête
à ce prix alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand c'est fini parce que mes amis game
is over moi il ya dix ans je fais comme
les filles font aujourd'hui c'est pas
juste
vous êtes méchant je joue plus j'ai
démissionné
et puis je suis parti j'ai commencé à
voyager
j'ai descendu le danube à vélo j'ai
remonté le gange jusqu'à la source
alors là près du temple
avant il y avait la source du gange le
glacier moi j'ai dû marcher 10 heures
pour trouver le lieu des glaciers j'ai
descendu d'autres rivières à madagascar
j'ai dormi dans la jungle birmane avec
des populations karen j'ai dormi dans
des orphelinats dans toutes sortes
d'endroits des ashrams j'ai cherché je
ne sais plus trop quoi au juste
puis j'ai trouvé plein de choses des
petites choses des grandes choses
merveilleuses des choses tristes
je veux ici mentionné trois rencontres
qui ont structuré ma vie d'abord j'ai
rencontré ma femme alors étonnamment je
les rencontrais dans mon village
d'origine
et cette rencontre et puis mes filles et
mon fils mes trois enfants au fur et à
mesure mon ancré dans une nouvelle
réalisation seul que en dépit de tout si
je devais recommencer à participer il
fallait que ce soit ici parce que je
n'ai pas de famille de rechange je n'ai
pas de peuple de rechange
il ne venait pas d' île de rechange
alors l'espoir est revenu j'ai j'ai
réalisé aussi que la fin d'un modèle ce
n'est pas la fin des haricots
au contraire c'est une immense
opportunité pour co créer de nouveaux
modèles
le modèle que
envie de vous proposer aujourd'hui c'est
le modèle de nous dans mon métier
d'origine pendant de la de l'ompa
augmente énergétique des îles j'utilise
cet anglicisme parce que empowerment
signifie pour moi la tête du maximum de
potentiel humain individuel ou collectif
en l'occurrence la tête de notre maximum
de potentiel énergétique
et puis dans power c'est l'homme le mot
anglais pour dire électricité et ce
n'est pas anodin lui-même conscience
habite le coeur de chaque être
oui la lampe pas vraiment énergétique
démarre par l'élévation de notre
conscience énergétique pourquoi parce
que la conscience l'élévation de la
conscience c'est la puissance de
transformation vous souvenez ce steak et
puis ce steak c'est le niveau de
conscience qui a changé et qui a
transformé ma réaction par rapport à la
viande
alors on va élever notre conscience
énergétique immédiatement vous êtes
prêts on va passer en revue un certain
nombre d'usagers quotidiens pendant une
heure et voir leur implication et leur
impact énergétique
alors commençons par cette simple lampe
led qui pendant une heure consomme 5
watts heure ensuite cette maison
traditionnelle des antilles qui est donc
bioclimatique qui consomme environ 200
watts heure noté qu'une maison moderne
avec climatisation et et piscine c'est
1000 watts heure ensuite passons à aux
transports ce véhicule électrique pour
faire 50 km amener votre famille à la
plage c'est environ 7000 water le même
trajet en suv 40000 water noté l'impact
des transports versus l'impact de
l'habitat et si vous êtes amateurs de la
pêche au gros
ce magnifique bateau 2 millions de watts
heure dix mille fois ma maison donc
c'est ça le les libations de la
conscience énergétique
que tous les passionnés de pêche au gros
dans la salle seront demain qu'ils
auront un choix paisible est conscient
entre 35 bateaux a dû millions water et
et le gagnant c'est lire un livre sur la
pêche au gros
maintenant qu'on a commencé à
transformer notre consommation
énergétique il s'agit désormais de de
s'attaquer à la production énergétique
alors on vous a bien entendu vendu la
sécurité énergétique et c'est vrai quand
vous allez à la pompe
vous avez de l'essence en général quand
vous allez à allumer votre lumière vous
avez d'électricité en général mais
l'homme par e mail énergétique nous
demande d'aller plus loin pourquoi ne
serait-ce que parce qu' il peut y avoir
des grèves vous ne maîtrisez pas le prix
de cette électricité et puis surtout
quand vous allez à la pompe
vous enrichissez des régimes dont vous
ne cautionnez pas du tout la politique
et quand on va quand on allume notre
lumière ont peut-être qu'on y est on a
un impact négatif sur des populations qu
on aurait adoré si on les avait connus
alors quelles sont les alternatives de
production d'énergie avant l'ère
pétrolière qui a duré environ 100 ans il
y avait le charbon etc site avant le
charbon pendant au finalement des
milliers d'années ce qui est intéressant
de noter c'est que l'homme a construit
tout son développement sur des énergies
renouvelables les bêtes de trait les
boeufs les chevaux l'eau de la rivière
avec des roues à aubes le vent avec des
moulins où le vent pour le transport
avec la voile
devinez ce qu'il ya de commun entre
toutes ces énergies renouvelables et
d'ailleurs de commun aussi avec le
pétrole et le charbon le soleil le
soleil et l'énergie prix mondial qui a
créé toutes ses énergies et oui la
température de la terre à deux endroits
différents
créer un flux le vent l'évaporation de
la mer amène cette eau de la montagne la
rivière
et la biomasse la biomasse
la magie de la photosynthèse par les
végétaux qui font la magie de
transformer de la matière minérale et de
l'eau en matière organique qui vous
donne la biomasse évidemment le pétrole
par biomasse et sédimentaires et les
transformations et le charbon de façon
similaire
autre bonne nouvelle c'est que le soleil
continue à briller tous les jours du
monde sur la tête de chacun d'entre nous
pour nous il l'accès le plus immédiat à
l'énergie du solaire aujourd'hui que la
technologie nous offre c'est le panneau
photovoltaïque le panneau photovoltaïque
vous permet d'éviter d'aller à 200 km au
large de l'afrique à 2000 mètres sous
l'eau récupérée du de l'énergie solaire
en fout de plus 5 millions d'années en
plus le panier le panneau photovoltaïque
est ce qu'elle est bonne c'est à dire
qu'on peut avoir des toutes petites
centrales sur vos doigts et de très
grosses dans les déserts au lieu d'être
confiné à avoir de grosses centrales au
diesel qui n'appartiennent qu'à un
nombre très restreint
on a désormais à huy étions un mythe
le mythe de l'énergie photovoltaïque
cher
le gestionnaire de réseau aux antilles
achètent en moyenne l'énergie solaire à
140 euros le mégawatt crête versus 300
euros le mégawatt crête pour l'énergie
disent elles poussent polluantes et
fossiles la limite principale du panneau
solaire c'est son intégration au réseau
car il a tendance à filer
c'est une énergie intermittente et donc
on ne la contrôle pas et le gestionnaire
de réseau nous annonce qu'au delà de 30
% de puissance photovoltaïque
instantanés on a du mal bon autre sujet
dans les îles une autre particularité
c'est que le transport constitue une
partie très importante finalement de
l'équation énergétique et donc il faut
aussi résoudre cette équation tourner
ses bas
le chantre américain de la transition
énergétique a démontré dans une étude il
y a deux ans qu'en 2025
85% des véhicules achetés seront
électriques ou hybrides rechargeables
le véhicule a ri électrique arrive qu'on
le veuille ou non
alors le véhicule électrique c'est un
moteur électrique et puis une batterie /
ou le moteur électrique à presque 200
ans
il est intrinsèquement supérieur aux
moteurs thermiques parce qu'il est plus
simple
il est donc plus robuste et plus fiable
et il a un rendement cinq fois meilleur
la batterie en revanche un impact
environnemental très mauvais mais il
faut comparer la batterie qui est un
équipement avec une durée de vie de 5 à
15 ans avec le pétrole qui a un impact
environnemental similaire mais qui
brûlait souvenez-vous 11 jours de
consommation mondiale combien de jours
de consommation mondiale d'orgies
énergétique pour cette forêt de canada a
brûlé et polluent à jamais non la vraie
limite du véhicule électrique
c'est son intégration au réseau la
puissance appelée comparer un
chauffe-eau électrique c'est 1000 à 2000
watts nautique le chauffe eau électrique
a doublé en dix ans la consommation du
territoire une climatisation 1000 à 2000
où apparaît doublement 10 15 ans
véhicules électriques tiers jusqu'à un
fan de 1000 watts et donc son impact sur
le réseau est extrêmement fort et
négatifs ici on a simulé la courbe de
charge électrique du réseau de la
martinique
le petit de la petite pointe rouge à
l'heure du soir c'est une simulation 2e
% de nos parcs actuel de véhicules qui
passent en électrique et qui se hisse
charge à ce moment là cette petite
pointe secousse suffit largement à
déstabiliser le réseau déstabiliser le
réseau du gestionnaire et à créer des
black out
alors imaginez 10%
ça fait longtemps que le réseau a sauté
juste pour comparer l'impact énergétique
n'est pas si fort puisqu'il est à peu
près du quart alors que deux points de
vue puissance c'est absolument énorme
nous avons donc nos deux briques de
langue par romain énergétique
mais ces deux briques là on
problème une limitation qu'on a vu on a
créé en 2013
une start up de l'empreinte énergétique
précisément pour faire sauter ces
verrous et nous y avons réussi c'est là
qu'intervient la troisième rencontre
mesdames et messieurs applaudissez chef
joseph
il est l'inventeur de l'internet alors
pas tout à fait tif joseph a dit l'homme
n'a pas inventé le tissu de la vie
l'homme n'est qu'un maillon de ce tissu
est donc tout ce qu'il fait à la vie il
le fait à lui-même très raisonnée avec
la phrase du mahatma gandhi mais qu'il
joseph la traduction anglaise de ce
qu'il a dit pour le tissu de la ville
utilise le web of life web
en ce qui me concerne le web c'est
l'internet et yves joseph nous a donné
la solution à notre problème nous allons
faire de lampard au monde énergétique
exactement comme on fait de l'internet
et donc là où avant vous avez une
encyclopédie écrit par cinq personnes de
l'autre bout du monde qui vous racontais
tout l'univers et de les allées vous
avez aujourd'hui l'internet la
possibilité que chacun exprime un petit
peu ça sa conviction du savoir on va
faire pareil sur le sur le réseau vous
aurez vos panneaux solaires votre
véhicule électrique et votre box
internet équivalente sera le compteur
idf et la nouvelle le nouveau le
énergétique la borne de recharge et
comme d'habitude d'un risque nous allons
faire une formidable opportunité
en combinant ces deux éléments qui sont
aujourd'hui un problème avec une même
intelligence universel nous allons
pouvoir les réguler sur le réseau
comment ça marche aujourd'hui notre
entreprise a réussi avec le gestionnaire
du réseau à recevoir des informations
des pilotes qui nous donne
l'autorisation de changer de ne pas
charger et demain de réinjecter pour
stabiliser le réseau de sorte que en
permanence
la puissance du véhicule électrique aide
à la flexibilité du réseau
après demain on est en train de
travailler sur du dynamic pricing c'est
à dire que vous allez rentrer dans une
bourse de l'énergie ou les prix de
l'électricité sera variable selon la
bande ans ou la rareté de l'énergie et
ça vous permettra à vous de participer
de rue un acteur am proud de l'énergie
dans votre territoire
en achetant et en revendant l'énergie de
façon fluide aux moments les plus
opportuns pour vous
une même conscience émerge une
conscience universelle habite le coeur
de chaque être
ce qui est marquant c'est que cette
conscience universelle elle habite le
coeur de chaque est pas la traite pas
les tripes a les membres la box internet
qui m'a donné accès à cette créativité
qui m'a donné le courage de me
transformer et de passer d'une vie qui
ne me correspondait pas dans sa
déconnexion une vie qui me correspond
beaucoup mieux dans sa connexion si mon
coeur c'est en me connectant ma
sensibilité en acceptant ma
vulnérabilité que j'ai pu passer le pas
je vous le demande
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui vous révolte
quelle chose inacceptable
avez vous pris l'habitude d'accepter en
tout cas soyez sûr quand vous connectant
à votre sensibilité à votre cure vous
aurez accès à l'immense intelligence
l'immense créativité de l'univers pour
passer le pas et devenir pleinement en
baroeul
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]